Hey Jammers! Dr. Brady here.
I got a question from General Brave Claw.
And they ask, "Have you ever heard of the chupacabra? And what is it?"
It's an interesting question.
I have heard of the chupacabra.
The chupacabra is like a mythical beast...
...like say Bigfoot, or the Abominable Snowman, or the Loch Ness Monster.
It's supposedly found in Latin America...
...and it's this creature which supposedly kills goats and other animals...
...and sucks their blood.
You know, a lot of people claimed to have seen it or seen its footprints...
...or maybe found some fur, kind of like Bigfoot or the Abominable Snowman...
...but there's no scientific proof.
In my opinion, it's just a mythical beast, the chupacabra.